die booster impfungen da gibt es einen
regelrechten run auf diese dritte
impfung die auffrischimpfung die
ständige impfkommission empfiehlt diese
impfung ja auch ab 18 jetzt also nicht
mehr nur für die über 70-jährigen genau
also da muss man sagen da herrscht beim
boostern unter das buch stand bei
senioren ist wirklich das
allerwichtigste was jetzt passieren kann
und da herrscht jetzt totales chaos die
stiko hat das erstmal nur für über
70-jährige empfohlen nach sechs monaten
dann kam gesundheitsminister jens spahn
hat gesagt eigentlich sollten sich alle
boostern lassen ganz viele senioren sind
hingegangen haben gesagt wenn wir das
noch nicht ganz sechs monate her sondern
vielleicht nur fünfeinhalb kriege ich
trotzdem den booster schott wurden nach
hause geschickt jetzt sagt ihr
entspannender jahr nach fünf monaten
wäre es eigentlich auch schon gut und
auch die stiko kommt jetzt sagt bald
werden wir es für alle über 18 empfiehlt
also verzeihung das ist die schlechteste
impfkampagne die schlechteste im
kommunikation die man sich vorstellen
kann warum ist das denn so schwer eine
einheitliche linie zu finden ich meine
das ist wie gesagt das wichtigste was
man tun kann und die bundesregierung und
ihre behörden und auch die stiko tun
alles dafür um die menschen zu verwirren
sollte einfach eine klare ansage geben
entweder nur senioren oder eben alle
fünf oder sechs monate muss man sich
einmal entscheidend festlegen und das
durchziehen und fertig verwirrung auch
wieder in den schulen auch in schleswig
holstein jetzt wieder masken pflicht für
alle schülerinnen und schüler wer blickt
da noch durch ja man muss ja sagen die
inzidenz bei schülern ist wahnsinnig
hoch in der altersgruppe zwischen 5 und
9 jährigen ist es ist es einfach man
könnte sagen verrückt wie hoch sie ist
aber ist es natürlich nicht verrückt
weil man die kinder halt ständig testet
bei den null- bis vierjährigen hält sich
die inzidenz in grenzen die werden kaum
getestet bei den fünf- bis neunjährigen
die sind halt drei vier fünf mal die
woche zum teil tests ausgesetzt und das
treibt natürlich die inzidenz werte nach
oben denn die inzidenz gibt ja nicht an
wie viele menschen sich anstecken
sondern nur wie viele
positiv positive tests durchgeführt
werden sowie viele infektion entdeckt
und es ist ja auch gar nicht klar wie
viele von den schülerinnen und schüler
überhaupt auch krank werden die
wenigsten zum glück zum glück die
wenigsten ich glaube das ist auch eine
maßnahme um die eltern zu beruhigen und
auch die lehrer zu beruhigen weil man
hört ja schon immer mehr eltern die sich
doch die frage stellen wenn sie jeden
tag die zeitung lesen die nachrichten
schauen die inzidenz und gerade bei
schülern so hoch sind wie gefährlich ist
es dann wirklich man kann ihnen die
angst zum teilnehmen und sagen das sind
wirklich nur einzelfälle die
schwerkranken es gibt andere
atemwegserkrankungen die regelmäßig
grassieren unter schülern die deutlich
gefährlicher sind beispielsweise das rs
virus